to present the short subjects there's a
young lady about town with whom I have
twice shared an apartment once we went
to my place once we went to her place
tonight we're together on television
here cocaine ladies and gentlemen meet
him Allah dues during the daytime known
as Shirin plan
hello and that's all I'm allowed to
ad-lib tonight
the nominees for Best live action short
short subjects are the concert James a
king corporation Ezra Baker homemade car
VP North America Limited James Hill an
occurrence at Owl Creek Bridge films du
centaur film Arctic Paul der obey and
Marcel he shot six sided triangle
Malaysian film production limited
Christopher miles that's Lee Stewart
production Walker Stewart and the winner
an occurrence at Owl Creek Bridge
accepting on behalf of holder obey and
Marcela shock-jock floor
mr. Paul de Roubaix and Marcela Shack
who are in Paris have asked me to
express their deepest gratitude to the
members of the Academy for this great
honor thank you
the nominees for the best achievements
in short subject cartoons are autumn a
Nia mm Hollis and Bachelor production
John Hollis the critic
Kim top crossbow productions Ernest
Pinto the game Agri Zagreb film
Doosan of the Kotick my financial career
National Film Board of Canada Poland Lo
and Tom Daley ian is the most enema 16
Carmen de vino and the winner is the
critic Ernest
I'm very grateful I'd like to save my
collaborator the wonderful and talented
Mel Brooks I'd like to thank Arnold
stone
Bob Heath and Columbia Pictures